oh hell yeah man football's back ah hell  no Antonio this is clearly not to go  thanks so much guys  my legs been trapped under this vending  machine all summer another bad thing  that's okay wait maybe it's not okay all  right I played nice I moved houses a B  you clearly just painted your old  Steelers house if a B wants to build on  the clip I'm sinking maybe up next the  top 1,080 offseason moments not ever can  be besties like coach and I even care  that I'm training on a baby chicken I  can't do this anymore I'm leaving hello  well you can do that remember you can  always find me in the throw of a  football Sandra look real or just a  dream we all had he was real he was damn  real Wow  subscribe to this channel by double  doinking below i mean double clicking  double kick below who brought up kicking  you know I don't get I mean I did it I  doubled oink didn't I'm over the double  doing